ces années de scolarité modérément
apprécié où vous n'êtes pas
nécessairement le bon élève et où vous
étiez pas forcément à l'aise au milieu
de ces classes ou comme je crois les
individualités c'est un peu ce que vous
dites
écoutez pour tout vous dire j'étais
quand même un petit garçon qui qui a on
avait demandé de sauter plusieurs
classes machin donc il ya quand même une
période où tout ça me paraît c'est très
simple et puis à une période comme
beaucoup de petits garçons et deux
petites filles à qui on demande de
sauter des classes au début ils
voulaient finissent par se faire très
très grave mon chien la pointe telles
qu'en fait il plonge une plongée plonge
et moi j'ai plongé parce que je je je
pense que je comprenais absolument pas
la possibilité de l'uniformité dans le
savoir et de l'ennui surtout c'est que
ce que je préfère au monde c'est
apprendre c'était vrai petit c'est vrai
aujourd'hui
je ne fais qu'à prendre tout le temps et
je bouffe toutes les infos que je peux
comme je peux avec un immense plaisir
non dissimulé
on m'a collé dans un truc où on m'a
expliqué que je ferais rien que machin
que truc et que et que à
quel point je me suis fait
chier mais tellement et c'est pas
possible de se faire chier que de
l'histoire pas possible de se faire
chier que du français n'est pas possible
de se faire chier avec de l'histoire de
la musique les cours d'histoire j'étais
en horaires aménagés moi ce qu'on
appelle un donc musique et coll mélanger
tous les jours il faut pas croire que la
musique était fun et chez eux alors
c'est un enseignement public un donc je
vais pas je vais pas cracher sur le truc
en france on peut apprendre la musique
totalement gratuitement et arriver
jusqu'à c'est mon cas au prix de paris
de madrid son ensemble
s'est pas privé donc c'est le noble
c'est louable il faut bien évidemment
c'est la france qui m'a appris la
musique faut pas déconner quand même
[ __ ] il ya tellement de façons de deux
passionnés avec sa de
simplement par quelqu'un qui vient vous
expliquer les choses autrement par un
pas par l'harmonie qui vous sera
présenté sous ces tentes plutôt que sur
l'autre par par le contrepoint par
n'importe quoi et en fait non non c'est
chiant c'est tout c'est chiant parce que
parce que c'est sévère parce que c'est
inventif parce que c'est pas passionner
basculement des ponts